[Music]
okay who's going second I'll go sir okay
all right all right I'll go okay wait
really big big Star Wars all right there
you go
give it up a guy well I'm using at the
moment you know what really I think we
became friends when we started that
group chat on and like just when we
started shooting like look we just
started having a great time on camera
and it just like we just had fun and we
just became friends right away you know
seems we have to be serious and then
Gaytan makes you laugh that those are
that I used to do that a lot
yeah you still do it yeah what's that
for Nikita
[Music]
probably the school scene when we had
when I was like you know dying which was
really hard that was kind of fun yeah
and in a way cuz like gating got to
carry me and I didn't have to walk I'm
like Superman
I had an injured ankle and an injured
knee that day same leg and spin couldn't
carry Millie oh yeah he couldn't carrier
and I had to carrier which was pretty
funny actually
Finn's a week sorry sorry since up
Amanda who's what Oh Kate me doesn't
totally I'm getting gains most like his
character get me that girl I couldn't
stop laughing um I had a problem
laughing from when they maybe laughs I'd
have to cut for break-ins too much so
I'd have to like I'd have to go and we
made you laugh a lot maybe off a little
time but then I think I was a serious
one yes you know I tell them to stop
keep it off the shut up and we would you
know Jesus very merely you wouldn't be
friends again like no
[Music]
yeah we were just thing onset for no
reason and they just harmonize on them
out of nowhere ready guys okay so mine
is basically like 11 she's a hot mess
and that's it that's it right that they
get this is a loose Lucas and Claire
dish right right right
got your gummy worms he loves gummy
worms tonight Luke and I know
yeah very organized yeah Lucas is very
picking you know great okay what I have
here I don't know but I think it looks
awesome I'm gonna try mine
why not I didn't food spray what it's
disgusting
well yeah can even put so much of that
food spray on there oh it doesn't taste
too bad yeah thank you guys so much